imaginez ethan hunt le héros de mission
impossible dans cet hélicoptère
il est venu sauver la martinique d'un
film à imaginer une james bond girl sur
une de nos plages
l'agent 007 en mission nous sommes à
sainte anne en martinique
[Musique]
nous avons les paysages des techniciens
ne nous manquait plus qu'un office
chargé de faire venir en martinique des
maisons de production pour y réaliser
des séries télévisées et pourquoi pas de
grosses productions cinématographiques
ce bureau a été créé par la ctn en plus
de faire venir ces boîtes de productions
françaises ou étrangères
il devra mettre en contact nos
techniciens du cinéma avec ceux qui
réalisent ces films mettre à leur
disposition des figurants ou des acteurs
ou les décombres
[Musique]
ensuite nous donner de la lisibilité sur
le plan national puisque une série de
télévision on le voit avec plus belle la
vie ou bien avec crime au paradis
on voit bien que ça rappelle un pays ça
fait ça porte un pays à hauts et ça
donne envie de visiter ce pays
ce soit des bateaux mais qui sont très
importants parce que notre jeunesse
on le sait a tendance à partir et il ya
une sous utilisation de notre territoire
par la production cinématographique
après la réunion et la guadeloupe
d'autres collectivités vient de créer
son bureau d'accueil des tournages
objectif faire découvrir au monde entier
nos plages nos paysages comme par
exemple ce sentier à case-pilote vous
pourrez partir une scène d'un film
et peut-être qu'un jour on verra à
courir sur nos plages ce fameux pirate
qui a rendu célèbre
certaines plages de la dominer
non